hello everyone and welcome to round 12
of the 1970 inter-zonal Tournament of
Palma de Majorca after five consecutive
wins Bobby Fischer had two draws a loss
against bent Larsen and then another two
draws so definitely not two going in the
way that he wanted it to go and now he
faces definitely one of the strongest
opponents in this tournament and he
played he has the black pieces against
him it is of course effing Yeller
not only a member of the world
Grandmaster elite but also he won the
Soviet Championship twice he qualified
for the grand for the candidates series
six times and we all know him to be a
producer of world chess champions as he
did the coach Boris Spassky and later
Anatoly Karpov so definitely a tough
customer but before we check out the
game I do have a nice photo challenge
pretty sure you all know this one but
you know in case you don't it's always
nice to learn something so here it is
best of luck to everyone sorry not that
that's a photo of them playing but I
have it prepared here who is this young
fellow here and there is a certain movie
that was made after this young fellow so
I think that pretty much says it all
best of luck to everyone now we don't
have a photo of this matchup in
particular but we do have a photo of
gellar playing against Fischer I don't
know the exact origin of the photo I'm
pretty sure it's from the 1962 Krakow
candidates tournament but I could be
wrong I'm pretty sure it is so there we
have it now let's check out the game
Geller opens with nice to f3 sorry about
that
he opens with Knight to f3 the reti
opening and Fischer goes Knight to f6
like in his yeah like in his a game of
the century and it is something that
after seeing that game I will often just
make my after after against the red
opening I will often make make four of
my first moves Knight of 6 Jesus Bishop
g7 and simply castles and you know if
Fischer play that it must be ok so c4 we
have G 6 g3 Bishop g7 Bishop g2 and fish
castles geller castles and now c6
favorite prepares d5 d4 d5 C capture Sun
d4c capture Sundy four in the now Knight
to e5 Fischer goes a Bishop to a5
prepares in Knight to e4 after gehler
develops the night so nice to see three
Fischer immediately wants to exchange
pieces we have Bishop to e3 and now
Knight captures on c3 pawn captures on
c3 and the knight to c6 now gellar
captures on c6 b captures on c6 and now
queen to a for developing the queen and
also attacking the c6 pawn Fischer
defends that Queen to b6 and now rook a
to C 1 and here a reasonable move would
be something like rook F to B 8
you know just developing the rope to a
nice square and then this a rock will be
defending the a pawn you can pull the a
pond you can infiltrate with the Queen
maybe you can offer a queen trade but
Fischer chooses a different idea it was
rook a to b 8 and leaves the f8 rook on
the beginning square and okay we have c4
brush-up capture some d4 Bishop captures
on d4 Queen captures on d4 and now III
so a temporary pawn sacrifice by Geller
but as you'll soon find out it is not
only temporary we have Queen to e5 and
now C capture Sun d5 seek after Sun d5
and now not immediately going after the
a7 pawn you could capture it but then
after ecigs
defending the d5 pawn gehler could start
pushing the f4 porn but then rook to b2
is coming rook the rook can come to b8
Fischer will get a lot of activity here
and it's a it's very unlikely that this
a four point will be able to do
something
so after C capture Sundy five look after
d1 first Geller goes after the d5 pawn
and develops the rook Fischer blocks
that we have e six and only now this
geller capture on a seven we have looked
at it attacking Geller's Queen Queen -
Queen to d4 and now Queen captures on d4
Iike a rock after sandy 4 and now
Fischer captures the past pawn rook
captures on a to e4 by Geller
we have captures the Bishop captures
Bishop
and rope captures so it's already moved
25 they've pretty much exchanged
everything there are four ropes left on
the board Fischer has four points Geller
has three points and all of the pawns
around the Kings side so basically all
in almost most likely this will be a
draw but Fischer is not interested in a
draw he wants to play this position out
which is something we very often see in
games of Magnus Carlsen
he doesn't mind playing a position that
is considered to be drawn even for for
you know two or three hours more and
such was the case as such was you know
the case of Fischer rook to b8 we have
rook to e3 and now g5 a Fischer prevents
wise from expanding with f4 or h4 we
have h3 King to g7 and now rook to c7 we
have King to g6 and rook to f3 Gallery
now goes after the f7 pawn so Fisher
plays f6 we have rook to e7 going after
the e6 pawn and now rook to e2 simply
defending g4 we have looked to be one
check King to g2 and the now comes rook
to to e1 and now if Geller isn't careful
if he plays a silly move like rook to a7
then he will be easily checkmated after
rook to g1 check King h2 Rock to h1
check King g2 and now Rock to g1 will be
checkmate
so after rook été 1 we have rook to a3
by Geller and now Fischer plays h5 rook
a to a7 now now a gallery is the one
actually threatening checkmate rook to G
7 8 7 and then the other rook will come
to the g7 to deliver checkmate Fischer
plays rook to g1 check we have King two
or three and now H captures on g4 with
check phone captors and now rook to b3
check the King has to move King to e2
and now capturing the g4 phone now the
King can move and there will be no
checkmate
so rook captures on e6 and now there are
still four four rooks on the board the
Fischer has two points against one point
on the King side still very very hard to
push for any any kind of advantage here
but Fischer is a relentless rook to be
one now we have King a rook to a six now
would
attack against the f6 pawn rook to f4
defending the f6 pawn and now rogue back
to a - Gellar cannot allow Fisher's play
rook to be to check and pick up the F
two pawns
so rook has to block it and now rook to
h1 Fischer wants the attack the F to
point via the h2 square we have rook
back to a6 now comes Luke to g4 rook to
be four and now rook to a for offering a
trade of rooks we have rook to be one
and now rook back to a8 rook to g1 and
now King to f3
we have rook to rook to b5 rook eight
285 again offering a trade of rooks and
Fisher declines rook to be three King to
e2 we have rugby to be one and now rook
back to eight repeating of the position
and the Fisher tries to infiltrate the
position with his scheme King to f5 rook
rook to to a5 delivering check King goes
to g4 now comes Roque for check King h5
and now rook to h8 check King to g6 so
Fisher just you know made a nice made a
nice trip with his King we have Luke to
GA check King to f7 and rook who goes
back to d8 and now rook to e1 check King
to f3 and now rook to e5 perhaps Fisher
will now be able to you know create a
nice outpost for his King on f5 r up the
d2 rook to f5 with check King moves and
now rook to e5 with check King to f3 and
now King to g6 we have rook to e4
offering a trade of rooks Fisher
declines rook to f5 check King moves to
e2 and then out comes rogue back to a5
rock to e3
Fisher tries King to h5 and now rook eat
the d3 rook a2 a1 we have looked to d8
and now comes f5 finally an opportunity
presents itself for Fischer to push up
on so he does it f5 King to f3
we have rook to a3 check Rock blocks and
now comes g4 with check King to f4 and
now comes Rock captures on d3 rook
captures on d3 and now rook to f1
attacking the f2 pawn
this is a well one of the critical
moments in the game here Geller should
have proceeded with King to g3 simply
defending the f2 point with the king and
after king g5 threatening F for this f3
move will be be sufficient to draw the
game after G captures rook captures you
can either move the rook or you will not
be able to put this pawn any further if
you have exchanged rooks of course this
is a completely drawn endgame now as the
King is occupying a nice square in front
of the the point the past point that is
supposed to be pushed so after rook to
f1 rook to d2 is played and now Fischer
finds a very nice idea here came to h4 s
plate allowing White's to capture the f5
pawn and gallery captures that King
captures an f5 and now comes a move that
Geller said that he thought it wasn't
really doing anything Fischer pushes g3
and now you see that of course you
cannot capture the pawn because the pawn
is pinned from the ff1 rook but geleris
all this he simply pushes f4 and now
what do you play here if you play
something like rook to F 2 then comes
rook to d6 threatening rope to h6
checkmate after you push G to rope comes
to g6 and you will not be able to put
this anywhere with the black pieces
so after f4 Fischer tried king to h3 now
comes Rock to D 3 by Geller pinning in
the g3 pawn king back to h4 by Fischer
and now comes look back to d2 Fischer
plays rook to e1 again simply offering
Geller and opportunity to blunder the
game and you know it's very interesting
what happens here here with a move like
rook to be - it's still hold about for
example rook to a8 rook to b7 offering
threatening to deliver some checks g2
and now simply rook to g7 stopping the
past pawn king to h3 now comes King to
e6 preparing to push his own past pawn
and now after the King prepares to
escort the pawn you will simply capture
it and after a 5 you will either have to
check the White King
constantly or you will have to wait for
white to promote the spawn and then
capture with the rook and it's a draw
but here after looked to a1 King defy
was played Geller simply thought I'll
simply make room for my pawn to be
pushed forward and then when Fischer
Queens his spawn I'll simply capture it
and then he will have to give up his
rook for my pawn as well but
unfortunately for geiler King to e5 was
a terrible blunder and you know who
could blame him this is move 71 I don't
know could be 6th 7th hour of the game
it's hard to say and now try to pause
the video here and try to find the only
move that wins the game for black and it
is a move that Fischer played so I will
give it a couple of seconds if you wanna
just you know check it out so you know
feel free to do it it's a very nice idea
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and for those of you who
just wanna enjoyed show if you found
work to h3 King to h3 then you will not
be winning the same game because now
black white can't seem to push f5 and
after something like rook to e1 check
you can use the f4 square for your king
rook to f1 check King simply moves and
now you will be able to push your own
pawn g2 is coming white can simply grab
the pawn and after King captures you
will simply play f6 King g6 push the
pawn pull the king and then promote and
black will have to sacrifice his rook
for the pawn but if you found King to g4
then you are winning this game you have
taken away the f4 square for whites King
and now it's all over if I was played by
Geller Fischer played rock to a5 check
if you found the rook to e1 check it's
also also playable in the game pressure
plate rope to f5 check and here Geller
simply resigned to the game DF
Foursquare is no longer available to the
King and it doesn't matter what you play
now next move
Fischer will capture the f5 point so for
example if you play King g4 rook
captures an f5 is played and now you
cannot stop this point from promoting
whatever you play rook to c2 rook to g5
is coming simply positioning the rogue
behind a passed pawn and after whatever
white plays you will simply move the
King
and now you cannot stop this point from
being promoted as both the king and the
rook Oryx escorting it so after rook to
a five check F in Geller resigned the
game and yet another victory for Bobby
Fischer in this tournament in round 12
so it's very interesting you know
playing so many moves 71 moves and who
knows how many hours into this game but
you know Fischer just you know wanted
wanted wanted to win this game and in
the end Gallery cracked so something
that often happens to crossings
opponents if you've seen caution versus
Navarro in the in round 1 of the bill
chess festival 2018 pretty much the same
thing but you know that's why when
someone offers you a draw if you feel
comfortable in your endgame skill you
know just play it out maybe when you
know if if you lose then you should
brush up on your endgame but you know if
it's a draw then it will be a draw if
not perhaps you'll grab a full point so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
around twelve of the two of the 1917
hamid america inter-zonal tournament
between effing collar and bobby fischer
i would like to thank Sauer of sin
Hector Coronado and Danny McCullough
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon
continuing the Bobby Fischer series and
perhaps with another game from the bill
chess festival thank you all and I'll
see you soon